>> Laura: TIME FOR ANOTHER
INSTALLMENT OF OUR SERIES
DEFENDING THE FIRST WHERE WE
EXPOSE THE ENEMIES OF THE
FIRST AMENDMENT, FREE EXPRESSION
AND FREE THOUGHT.
HIGH SCHOOL TEACHER IN
BROWNSBURG, INDIANA, SAYING THAT
HE WAS FORCED TO RESIGN AFTER
YOU CHALLENGE THE DISTRICT'S
POLICY ON TRANSGENDER STUDENTS.
THAT POLICY REQUIRES TEACHERS TO
ADDRESS THESE STUDENTS BY THEIR
PREFERRED NAME INSTEAD OF THEIR
BIRTH NAME.
TEACHER JOHN SAYS THAT THAT
VIOLATES BOTH HIS RELIGIOUS
BELIEFS HE AND HIS
CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHT.
I RECENTLY SPOKE TO MR. CUVIER
AND HIS ATTORNEY AND I BEGAN BY
CHALLENGING ON WHETHER THE
SCHOOL DISTRICT REALLY VIOLATED
THE CLIENT'S RIGHTS.
YOU CAN'T USE THE CLASSROOM FOR
ANYTHING YOU WANT TO DO SPEECH
WISE, I MEAN, YOU ARE UNDER
CONTRACT WITH THE SCHOOL.
IF SOMEBODY IS A TEACHER OF
ANTHROPOLOGY WANTS TO GET UP AND
TALK ABOUT HIS OR HER VIEW ON
NAZISM OR CREATIONISM, THAT IS
MY FREE SPEECH, GAS, BUT YOU ARE
UNDER CONTRACT WITH THE SCHOOL
TO TEACH SPANISH.
SO YOU CAN BE FIRED FOR THAT,
CORRECT?
>> YES, TO YOUR POINT, WE
BELIEVE THAT THERE IS A
CONSTRUCTIVE DISCHARGE HERE.
THAT THEY UNREASONABLY THREW OUT
AN ACCOMMODATION THAT WAS IN
PLACE.
THEY ACTUALLY HAD A WRITTEN
AGREEMENT TO ALLOW JOHN TO
EXPRESS HIS CONVICTIONS BY USING
ONLY LAST NAMES OF ALL OF THE
STUDENTS.
THAT REASONABLE ACCOMMODATION
WAS TOSSED OUT BY THE
ADMINISTRATION AFTER THE SCHOOL
YEAR.
HE EITHER RESIGNS, FOLLOWS THE
LINE OF THE SCHOOL, USING THESE
TRANSGENDER NAMES THAT WERE NOT
AS HE SAID THE BIRTH NAMES OR HE
WILL BE SUSPENDED AND THEN
TERMINATED.
THOSE WERE THE CHOICES.
SO FROM THE STANDPOINT OF OUR
LEGAL POSITION, WE BELIEVE THAT
WE HAVE AN ILLEGAL DISCHARGE.
THAT IS NUMBER ONE.
NUMBER TWO, THE CONSTITUTIONAL
ISSUE IS CAN THE GOVERNMENT
COMPEL HIM TO VIOLATE HIS
RELIGIOUS BELIEFS?
THERE IS SUFFICIENT FEDERAL LAW
THAT SAYS THAT THEY MUST MAKE A
REASONABLE ACCOMMODATION IF HE
HAS RELIGIOUS BELIEFS.
IN THOSE CASES THEY ARE WELL
ESTABLISHED AROUND THE COUNTRY.
WE BELIEVE THAT THIS IS A NEW
ONE, BECAUSE IT DEALS WITH AN
INSIDIOUS EFFORT BY A
GOVERNMENTAL ENTITY, IF YOU
WILL, A SCHOOL PAID BY TAXPAYER
FUNDS.
SO WE SEE THIS AS A DIFFERENT
WRINKLE THAT WE HAVE SEEN BEFORE
IN THE CASES COMING UP.
>> Laura: I THINK THAT THE
STUDIES ON TRANSGENDER IS HIM
ARE VERY DIFFICULT.
FIRST OF ALL, THERE IS NO REAL
LONG PEER-REVIEWED STUDY THAT WE
CAN LOOK AT ADS WITH WHETHER
HORMONE BLOCKERS, WE DO NOT NEED
TO GET INTO THAT, IT IS NOT
RELEVANT.
BUT THERE IS A REALLY EXPLOSIVE
GROWTH IN KIDS CALLING
THEMSELVES TRANSGENDER.
AND JUST IN THE BRITISH STUDY,
THEY WENT FROM I THINK IT IS 94
REFERRALS AS GENDER DYSPHORIA,
THE TECHNICAL TERM FROM
2009-2010.
94 AT THE CLINIC TO NOW BETWEEN
2016-2171986 REFERRALS INCLUDING
SOME OF THOSE WHERE CHILDREN ARE
YOUNGER THAN SIX YEARS OF AGE.
PEOPLE ARE THINKING THAT THIS
COULD BE GENDER AFFIRMING
TREATMENTS AND ACTUALLY
ENCOURAGING KIDS WHO CALL
THEMSELVES TRANSGENDER, MOST
GROW OUT OF IT.
THAT IS THE WAY THAT IT IS.
BUT OTHER STUDIES, ADOLESCENT
HEALTH JOURNAL SAYING THAT THEY
ARE TWO TO THREE MORE TIMES
LIKELY TO SUFFER FROM
DEPRESSION, SUICIDE, OTHER
MENTAL DISORDERS, VERY DIFFICULT
MENTAL DISORDERS, VERY DIFFICUL
DIFFICULT.
SO ARE YOU ACTING IN PART OUT OF
CONCERN FOR THESE KIDS THINKING
THAT THEY ARE GETTING BAD ADVICE
FROM THEIR PARENTS OR OTHERS?
>> I DO REALLY CARE ABOUT THESE
STUDENTS, THAT IS WHY I WANTED
TO SIDESTEP THE WHOLE ISSUE.
I WANTED TO FOCUS ON TEACHING
THE KIDS ORCHESTRA AND BEING
ABLE TO REACH OUT TO THEM.
AND I HAVE BEEN ABLE TO OVER THE
COURSE OF THE YEAR CULTIVATE
FRIENDLY RELATIONSHIPS WITH MY
STUDENTS INCLUDING THE
TRANSGENDER STUDENTS OF MINE.
AND I REALLY WANT TO CONTINUE
TEACHING THEIR PET I LOVE THESE
KIDS AND I WANT TO CONTINUE THAT
WORK.
>> Laura: JOHN, WHAT WAS THE
REACTION FROM THE OTHER
STUDENTS?
THEY MUST HAVE HEARD ABOUT THIS.
WHAT GRADE ARE WE TALKING ABOUT
>> 9-12.
>> Laura: WHAT WAS THE
REACTION OF THE OTHER STUDENTS
WHEN THEY CHANGE NAMES AT THE
MIDDLE OF THE TERM?
>> IN MY CLASS, BECAUSE I HAD
BEEN REFERRING TO STUDENTS BY
THEIR LAST NAME ONLY, IT HAS NOT
REALLY BEEN A TOPIC THAT HAS
BEEN DISCUSSED.
WE FOCUSED ON WORKING TOGETHER
AS A TEAM TO CREATE BEAUTIFUL
MUSIC.
I THINK THAT I'VE BEEN
SUCCESSFUL IN BEING ABLE TO
CREATE A CULTURE AND MY
CLASSROOM THAT THEY ARE
RESPECTING EACH OTHER AND I
EXPECT THEM TO.
AND I CARED FOR THEM AND DO
RESPECT THEM ALL.
>> Laura: AND THE SUIT BEING
FILED IN FEDERAL COURT?
>> WE HOPE NOT, WE HOPE THAT THE
SCHOOL BOARD AT 6:30 ON MONDAY,
RECANTS, ALLIANCE OF FREEDOM
BROUGHT ME INTO THIS TO TRY TO
AVOID LITIGATION IF WE CAN GET
IT HANDLED, THAT'S WHAT JOHN
WANTS AND WHAT WE WANT.